as the phillies wake up today on friday
afternoon
they find themselves in the postseason
as of now a half game ahead of the st
louis cardinals but they've got some
work to do they've got the doubleheader
today against the blue jays
in fact they're the road team in game
one the home team in game number two and
this is what we're talking about the
phillies are one game under 500. they've
had a
ton of frustrating losses here in 2020
in this 60 game schedule
but if they can hold off the cardinals
the brewers of the mets who obviously
are back in it after taking two of three
then they could find themselves
in the first season robbie ray coming
off his best start as a blue jay picked
up his first
win as a blue jay last time out five
innings four hits
he allowed one run two walks and struck
out five and his fastball was electric
so back-to-back walks puts two on with
one out
that brings up d.d gregorius that ball
is pulled deep to right field going back
hernandez and it is off the top of the
wall
harper is going to score boom being held
at third
rbi double for gregorius his 33rd rbi of
the year the phillies jump out to a one
nothing lead
it's their 41st first inning run
deedee gets a fastball out over the
plate again and he just
turns on and here's where you got to
finish it if you're robbie ray scott
kingery as you can see struggling
hitting just 150.
and he got him ray had to work really
really hard but only gives up one run in
the top of the first
well here's zac eflin philly's need a
big outing from f1 his era's
up to 5.01 ruben two and two and did not
look good in his last outing against the
marlins yeah the key is for him to get
ahead
and to be able to utilize his sinker to
his advantage the chet's playing in the
sixth game since coming back
swinging a biscuit breaking ball
and one out here in the first one away
and one of the hottest hitters not only
for the blue jays but just
overall lourdes guriel junior
swagga to miss another curveball
and gurriella strikeout victim number
two mate oscar hernandez
swagger to miss he got him three
strikeouts on
three two strike curve balls for zach
kefla no
runs one hit and one man left
it's one and two the pitch to the rookie
swing at a miss chased a high slider
and moniak is down on strikes on roman
quinn the center fielder for the
phillies
and he does what a nice inning for
robbie ray three up three down with a
couple of strikeouts
it's one and two one two chased a high
fastball
and a four pitch strikeout for zach
eflin and a very quick one two three
inning of work
there's alec bone he walked his first
time up
what a play ray with a backhanded stab
at the ball
and he'll get the outed first as
mccutchen comes to third two down
and now a chance to get out of this if
he can get didi gregorius
02 again and he got him robbie ray
strikes out d.d gregorius to strand a
runner
two down and here's mickey moniak not
every you know you read the names not
every number one pick is
is a lock that's for sure ray bounces
back after the lead off base hit
strikes moniak out jay's coming up at
the bottom of the four
guriel's having a pretty good season
miss
outstanding slider right there nice and
tight almost looked like a
cutting type slider this time and it
brings randall gritchik up
coming back from the injury there's a
ground ball to short stop that could be
two to one
second for one and over to first in time
a six four three double play
and here's bryce harper oh man
that ball is crushed the wind will
not affect it inside the pole
oh a two-run home run for a harper
and it's a three-nothing ball game
and now phil gosselin is hitter and a
looper out to left that'll be in for a
base hit second hit of the day
for gosselin a run is in it's an rbi
single four-nothing phillies well andrew
knapp is the eighth man to hit
in this inning quarters go pitches lined
it to right field of base hit
one is in gosselin runs well he's gonna
score
knapp is on his way to second he's gonna
go yeah tom that's a big base hit
runners going with a 3-2 count with two
outs and
he ends up with a triple travis shaw
struck out in his first at bat
got him for the second time six
strikeouts for effluent
[Music]
swing of the miss all that helps seven
strikeouts for effluent
and the g's go down one two three all
right so two away
and foams up the slide in between harper
and gregorius and he has not
missed a b no there's a one hopper out
to right field rounding third heading
for ole miss quinn he'll score standing
rbi single for bulma just keeps on
hitting with runners in scoring position
seven nothing phillies and they're two
outs
here in the seventh inning swag and a
miss he got him nine strikeouts for zach
keflan
as he completes the four hit shutout and
the phillies win it
seven nothing to take game one of this
doubleheader